[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
scarlett johansson sues disney over the
release of the black widow movie
and several charges dropped against the
doomsday couple
why lori balodebel and her husband chad
are no longer charged with destroying
and concealing evidence in the deaths of
her two children
plus a man dies 35 years after a
babysitter is convicted of shaking him
as a baby
now the babysitter is back behind bars
there
there are very few homicide cases where
you can say you have something that is
this well documented and
why was this mass found in robert
durst's possession when he was arrested
for the murder of his best friend
the real estate era's shocking admission
it was her or me i had no choice
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
scarlett johansson is suing the walt
disney company claiming a breach of
contract over the black widow movie
release
before i got this family
i mean mistakes black widow launched
onto the big and small screens earlier
this month
released simultaneously in theaters and
on disney plus
but now the black widow herself is
claiming that cost her big bucks
one thing's for sure
i'm done running from my past in a newly
released lawsuit attorneys for scarlett
johansson
said she had a contractual promise for
the movie to be released exclusively
in movie theaters for a period between
90 and 120 days
the movie's release was delayed several
times due to the pandemic
in march 2021 disney plus announced
black widow will also be available to
subscribers for an additional 30 dollars
the complaint states the picture grossed
more than 60 million dollars
on the streaming app in its first
weekend alone it goes on to
question why would disney forego
hundreds of millions of dollars in box
office receipts
by releasing the picture in theaters at
a time when it knew then
theatrical markets was weak rather than
waiting a few months for the market to
recover
the walt disney company responded
telling law and crime there is no merit
whatsoever to the filing
saying it disregards the horrific
effects of the pandemic and
the move's release enhanced her ability
to earn additional compensation
on top of the 20 million dollars she's
received to date
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney matthew mangino
and terry austin matthew is scarlett
johansson accusing disney of pushing
consumers to watch
where her contract gives her less could
that be more than just a breach of
contract
well it appears that it might because
obviously
they're alleging that disney didn't live
up to their end of the park
but there appears to be something a
little more sinister here
in that um you know disney used this
film to promote
their uh own streaming uh
uh operation through their network uh so
they didn't go into the studio into the
theaters with this uh film
they decided to use uh the streaming uh
opportunities that they had that also
promoted their business that generated
60 million dollars in revenue so
is there something more sinister here
than just hey we couldn't do this we
didn't live up to the end of our bargain
or did we intentionally disney
intentionally
uh go after this opportunity to to raise
the
uh image of their streaming operation
interesting question indeed terry the
first thing that came to mind
was force major which a lot of people
who couldn't have weddings during the
pandemic
understand but doesn't a pandemic kind
of change the contract
well brian it might but everything
depends on
the wording of the contract these are
two sophisticated parties
so theoretically they should have had a
forced major provision
in the contract but basically what that
provision says is that
both parties are freed of their
obligation if there is an event like a
pandemic
but we know that disney and in fact
scarlett johansson
they lived up to their obligations so
she can
argue that because they did do some of
their obligations
they should have come back to her and
renegotiated
those terms so she could get some
additional money as well 50 million
dollars if that was the amount
is a lot of money for anyone absolutely
enforced majority it's a fancy word for
seeing
something unforeseeable or an act of god
that comes up in a lot of contracts
we'll see how those two parties
negotiate those terms
turning now to more top legal news and a
major development in the doomsday duo
case
prosecutors have dropped several charges
against the couple
lori vowell and her husband chad dabo
are charged with murdering lori's two
children
j.j valo and tyler ryan authorities
discovered their bodies buried in
shallow graves
on day bell's property the dabels were
initially charged with destroying
altering and concealing evidence of the
children's death on thursday
at the request of the prosecutors the
judge dismissed those charges without
prejudice
to quote serve the ends of justice and
for the effective administration of
court's business
lori's murder case is on hold for now
while she's deemed incompetent to
proceed
chad is scheduled to stand trial in
november
terry the prosecution has until early
august to declare
if they'll seek the death penalty
against chad dabo what do you think
they'll do
you know it's about 50 50 if you ask me
i think that most prosecutors these days
are a bit
hesitant to seek the death penalty
because they know
if the jury recognizes that the death
penalty is part of the case
it might be hard to get 12 members to
come to a consensus
the other issue with the death penalty
brian as we all know
is that there are multiple appeals and
so
it would take years in any event to
enforce so i'm not so sure they're going
here all right we'll see how it plays
out like we said just a few weeks until
that decision must be made
matthew how do you think the dismissal
of the lower charges changes chad's case
if at all i i don't really think that it
that it changes
his case i mean brian this case is about
murder this is a homicide
uh and that's where the prosecution
wants to focus their attention
they don't want the jury to be
distracted by any other issues
any other charges uh that aren't
significant here
this is a a homicide case it's to the
death of two children
and that's what the prosecution wants to
focus their
their uh their priority on with regard
to this matter
so it could be mad to kind of look at
what you're saying
could this be them laser focusing on a
single issue to do a better job of
prosecuting could that be it
yeah i think that's it i think that they
they want to focus
on what's important here and that's the
homicide charges
they don't want to distract the jury
they don't want to spend time
on issues that really aren't important
in the grand scheme of things
they want to go after chad and laurie
ultimately for murder and that's where
they want to focus their attention
all right let's see how that laser focus
helps them as this case continues like
we said
chad dabal expected to go to trial
sometime in november lori valo day bell
is still
anticipating to see whether or not she's
found competent to proceed
still ahead on law and crime daily jury
selection in the tennessee trial of a
man
accused of killing a cop then lighting
his body on fire
but first why a former babysitter is now
behind bars the decades old case
now ruled a murder our legal analysis
after the break
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back a woman is behind bars
accused of shaking a baby nearly 40
years ago
but that baby grew up and died two years
ago
at the age of 35. law on crime's angela
levy is here with more on the death of
benjamin dowling
brian prosecutors say benjamin dowling
was just five and a half months old when
he suffered a massive brain
injury after being shaken now decades
later his former babysitter
is charged with murder
benjamin dowling was a beautiful baby
boy in 1984.
one day his mom said she dropped him off
at babysitter terry mccurchie's home and
when she returned
something was wrong she said in a
statement she took him to the hospital
where doctors determined he had been
shaken
benjamin spent the rest of his life in a
wheelchair
there there are very few homicide cases
where you can say you have something
that is
this well documented forensic death
investigator joseph scott morgan has
seen similar cases
benjamin dowling died in 2019 and
despite terry mccarchy having entered
into a plea deal in 1985 where she
served 60 days in jail on weekends
after pleading no contest to attempted
murder and aggravated child abuse
a broward county grand jury has indicted
mccurchie for murder
morgan talks about the evidence
prosecutors likely have
can you imagine if this thing goes to
trial when they walk in
internet they're going to have to use
hand trucks
to bring in the documents we've got 34
years of documentation relative to this
poor man's death after all of this time
the autopsy report lists benjamin's
cause of death as homicide caused by
sequelae of abusive head trauma
now sequelae is this this bizarre world
that means something has happened
in relation to another pathological
event that occurred in the past
benjamin's parents issued a lengthy
statement part of it reads we cherish
our time with and memories of benjamin
and we continue to support him through
our belief
that there should be justice for
benjamin
now published reports quote mccurchy is
saying back at the time that this
happened that
benjamin had fallen off of her couch and
that she was innocent
joseph scott morgan said that those
kinds of injuries likely would not have
been caused by a simple fall from a
couch
brian thanks angela let's bring back
criminal defense attorney matthew
mangino and terry austin
terry have you ever heard of a murder
that took decades to complete
how can you intend to kill someone and
they died 35 years from now
you know brian this is a first for me
but it doesn't mean it hasn't
happened before usually under criminal
law the requisite attempt
is going to exist at the time of the
crime but we have seen cases
where there is an intentional assault
and then
there is a murder because there's a
death a few days later a few weeks later
but 35 years later is a very long time
and as we just heard there has to be a
lot of evidence that actually connects
that original act to the death of the
victim so
here in this case it sounds like that
evidence probably
does exist and the rationale makes sense
brian
now matthew you have ran on the issue of
a person dying years after they were
injured
can you tell us more about these types
of cases yeah
although it sounds unusual it it
it does happen and about 10 years ago in
philadelphia
a police officer died from gunshot
wounds that he received in 1966
he was paralyzed by that gunshot the
defendant was sentenced to 20 years in
prison
he subsequently died in 2007 in 2010
they tried that same guy that same
defendant
for his murder and actually after uh
a jury trial he was acquitted uh so
although they
they pressed the issue they weren't able
to convince a jury
that the death of the police officer was
caused by that gunshot wound
uh 40 years earlier in 1966.
yeah those wheeled truck barrels of
however joseph scott morgan described
that of evidence coming in
you better believe the defense turner's
going to try to find any reasonable
doubt within it
terry what's terry what's terry sorry in
jeanette what's terry mckersh's status
well right now she is being held in a
jail in fort bend county
texas that is where she was living at
the time of her arrest
earlier this month and she has not yet
been back to
been brought back to florida by
authorities to answer to these charges
we expect that to happen
sometime soon but a future court date
has not yet been set
mccurcy is not contesting or fighting
her return to florida
all right it's going to be interesting
in case that's going to be like joseph
scott morgan's had
so many documents when it comes to the
medical examiner to examine
as to whether or not this is a cause of
this poor poor young man's death we'll
make sure to bring you two back
when we get more coming up on law and
crime daily a convicted bank robber
turned youtuber reflects on his 31 years
behind bars
plus the accused killer clown is back in
court yet another delay in the
mysterious cold case
who really murdered a florida mother in
front of her own son
welcome back jury selection is now
underway in the tennessee trial of a man
accused of shooting an officer and
setting fire to his patrol car with the
victim's body still inside
stephen wiggins is charged with first
degree murder vehicular arson
and abuse of a corpse for the death of
dickinson county sheriff's deputy
sergeant daniel baker baker was killed
back in may 2018
investigators say wiggins was driving a
stolen vehicle shot baker several times
dragging baker's body into baker's
patrol vehicle then drove the car
several miles
then set it on fire wiggins was arrested
after a two-day manhunt
his trial has been delayed several times
due to the pandemic
if convicted wiggins could face the
death penalty opening statements are
expected monday
be sure to tune in to the law and crime
network for gallaudet gavel coverage
the trial of the so-called killer clown
has been delayed again
sheila keen warren is accused of
dressing up like a clown
getting out of a chrysler and shooting
and killing marlene warren in may
1990 in the doorway of her home marlene
warren was the wife of keane warren's
current husband
michael warren the case was called for
decades until dna evidence
led to the defendant's arrest in 2017.
earlier this week
the trial was delayed until march 2022
on friday the judge granted another
delay until may of next year
she faces up to life in prison
why would a convicted felon turn into a
youtuber
raymond reed got out of prison about two
months ago and is sharing what happened
that got him locked behind bars on the
latest episode of cocktails and
cocktails
i i actually filled out a deposit slip
and uh
on the back of the deposit slip i just
wrote empty your drawer quick quickly
and quietly
and she looked at me i gave her the
notes she gave me the money i put the
money in my coat pocket and i turned
around and walked out
and then i got in my car jumped back in
went to the hotel room
started counting the money found the
tracking device oh
and i was like i didn't even recognize
what it was until i saw the
the m for motorola oh
and i was like oh lord so i wrapped it
up and uh
tried to flush it down the toilet and
then the toilet backed up
that happens to howard quite a bit too
for different reasons but
i have trouble with a woman yeah and
then uh
by the time i got to the ho like when i
opened the door because i was gonna go
get made off the door
police was there
when we come back robert durst on trial
for the murder of his best friend
the shocking admission the real estate
air said to the state's mystery witness
that broke the case wide open
[Music]
welcome back we're heading to california
for the trial of robert durst where the
jury heard
from the state's key witness who says
the release date error confessed
robert durst is on trial for the murder
of his best friend susan berman in
december 2000
durs was arrested in 2015 and
prosecutors say this latex mask
along with thousands of dollars were
found in his new orleans hotel room
the state alleges dur shot berman to
prevent her from coming forward
about what she knew about the
disappearance of durst's first wife
kathy in 1982 and a mutual friend of
dursen berman testified in 2017
that berman revealed to him the truth
about why kathy is missing
susan said to me specifically that bob
killed kathy and i said no he didn't
she said yes he did and we argued about
that
she said we love both of them
kathy's gone we love bob
we need to protect you bob killed kathy
i said how do you know she said he told
me
prosecutors then asked shaven about a
dinner he had with duras in 2014.
durst allegedly wanted to talk about
kathy and susan
the dinner concluded
and it was then that i as we got up to
leave i realized that we hadn't
discussed the two things that he had
mentioned kathy and susan
it felt kind of weird that i didn't
bring it up
we walked out the door
this is hard we walked out the door
and on the sidewalk i said
you wanted to talk about susan
and bob said
i had to it was her or me
i had no choice
and then he turned to walk away and said
he wanted to talk about kathy and he
just kept walking away nothing more was
said
on cross defense attorneys asked shaven
if he made up this alleged confession
and misheard what the defendant said
you know because the city mumbled
something
what you said i can't really put it
together
what it was so you're telling
um the prosecutors on a tape recorded
or recorded conversation that you didn't
know what was said
i can't really put it together what it
was
those are your words aren't they
yes i don't remember that conversation
but yes here's the
reason i'm asking you that did you have
in mind
when you met had this conversation what
you have now
claimed in court that is that bob said
it was her me i had no choice did you
have it in your mind then well i knew it
yes
but you said yes i did you said to the
district attorney's office i can't
really put it together so that's why i
need to talk about it then
matthew what do you think of the
prosecution's style direct
and did he get what he was after with
shaven
well brian uh you know as we all know um
you don't get to pick
your witnesses in a case uh and uh nick
chauvin
is not uh the the best witness uh
unfortunately he said that he never
discussed this matter
uh with robert durst at one point uh
said that he went to dinner with him but
the
topic never came up said that uh he said
something but it was
garbled and he couldn't understand it
and now he says that
that he says it was either he uh her or
me
and that robert dors told him that so
that's not the best witness to have um
you know and
you have to you know tread lightly
because you have an individual who
certainly is sworn as allegiance at
least at some point
to robert durst and now uh you know some
time later is willing to say hey
he told me it was it was me or her um
you know so
so you know this the the jury is not
going to be enamored
uh by uh this gentleman's testimony
yeah to prosecutor lewin's credit he's
seen more hostile
witnesses in this case that i've seen in
eight years of practicing uh law in
brooklyn so
kudos to him for that terry based on the
testimony you've heard so far in this
trial
do you think shaven misunderstood durst
or even i don't know
lied all together about what durst told
him
listen i think first of all matt makes
some very good points here but i
completely
agree and understand with what chavin
went through and why he's changing his
testimony there's no question in my mind
that durst said at the end of that
dinner
that it was either him or susan and we
have
teresa saying and that's the wife of
javen that
at the time he told her that and i think
his hesitancy
was only because he's such a close
friend to durst so i believe
[Music]
[Music]
you